des accusations proférées en pleine
assemblée générale des nations unies
pendant son intervention pré enregistré
le président des états unis a
directement tenu pour responsable la
chine dechy jean ping
selon lui les autorités chinoises ont
laissé le virus infecte et le monde
qualifiant encore une fois le co vide 19
de virus chinois donald trump a demandé
à l'onu dans tirez les conséquences
nous devons exiger de la nation qui est
à l'origine de ce fléau mondial qu'elle
rende des comptes
je veux parler de la chine lorsque le
virus est apparu
la chine a interdit les voyages à
l'intérieur du pays tout en permettant
que des vols quittent la chine est
infecte le monde
une déclaration à laquelle le président
chinois n'a pas pu réagir son discours
étant lui aussi pré enregistrée pour
l'occasion
l'ambassadeur chinois à l'onu s'est
chargé de répondre à donald trump
[Musique]
si quelqu'un doit être tenu pour
responsable
ce sont les états unis pour avoir perdu
tant de vies avec leur attitude
irresponsable
le milliardaire républicain dont la
gestion du coc vite 19 et controversés
une gestion qui pourrait bien peser sur
ses chances de réélection lors de la
présidentielle du 3 novembre à six
semaines du scrutin les états unis ont
atteint mardi un nouveau record de
victimes de la pandémie le 200.000e
décès attribués au kovy 19 a été
enregistré